wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
okay wir müssen besser und schneller
spielen besonders die technik ist bei
uns ein schlechter geworden außerdem
höher springen und mehr tore schießen
prinz max ist ein bescheid du bist der
schnellste
ok max ist vielleicht auch stößt aber
ich kann ihnen weitesten schießen
tarek spielt am schlechtesten ich muss
mich trotzdem erstmal ausruhen ausruht
ja gute sportler machen dreimal pro
woche training ich mache krafttraining
das wichtigste ist die ernährung ist
viel obst trinkt keinen alkohol und
rauch nicht und trinkt viel wasser gut
ihr fitness profis dann zeig mal was wir
drauf haben
[Musik]